Paul Schwartz was there the Giants beat
writer for the New York Post and he's
been doing it a long time I think since
the mid-90s and I I can't help but
wonder what you think those Giants fans
are feeling like today after what they
witnessed last night Paul hi Dan well
it's what they witnessed was the only
thing that could stop Daniel Jones was
the sound and fury of Mother Nature
right you know they say you know it'll
be a cold day in hell but something
happens well when this may be a sea
change with the Giants with Daniel Jones
and Eli Manning the skies open up and
the thunder and lightning will come from
the heavens and that is exactly what
happened last night yeah it was pretty
walkable do we know I do we know any
more about Daniel Jones today than we
did two days ago I I think so I mean we
don't know that he's going to Canton
right now or he's going to be starting
September 8 against the Cowboys but look
any time you do something for the first
time it's a little check that you can
put next to it right he did this so you
know did I know did anyone know how he
was going to respond to his first NFL
action and he had never been in MetLife
Stadium until last night I mean the
Giants don't practice there right they
practice in the parking lot near there
so you know he walks into a stadium for
the first time I get acclimated gets in
the game early goes five for five so
yeah I think it's a checkmark that the
first taste of this he could handle
unquestionable was it a better headline
better story if Daniel Jones played well
or he didn't play well well when you
look at a glass is it half-full or
half-empty are you a lover or a hater
you know you know how do you wake up in
the morning right well how do you feel
you know is it going to be a good day or
a bad day yeah no I think it's it's look
there's been a lot of gloom and doom
around the Giants for a while here and
you know there's all season people are
picking up to be a bad team people Mokpo
daniel Jones pick at number six so I
think if he goes out there and goes over
five with two interceptions it's just
or piling on this was awful Dave
gallivant insane this team is going down
we're so hope springs eternal in August
it should anyway right and when your
rookie quarterback as a perfect passer
rating it certainly fuels some of that
and I think it's good for business in
our point you anything did anybody ask
Eli what he thought of daniel Jones
performance no you I was not available
after the game he was fairly available
during the game right it was a three and
out done and and that that's not look
this was a campy offer for you I I mean
this was one series that's all it was if
he had thrown for pass complete them all
they went down and got a touchdown or a
field goal he still would have been out
so but adjust the juxtaposition of this
is hard to is hard to ignore
Eli comes in go three and out daniel
Jones comes in lights it up and then the
skies open up and there's a foul rain
delay and they take them out and dumb
you know and that's what we're left to
it right that's what we're left so were
left with his is pretty good lead on the
bone here that you want what are the
expectations of this team like I said I
think inside I said I believe that they
seola dari
a teamollie subject that they're a young
team they are a young team it's not a
belief I mean the defensive back feels
incredibly young daniel Jones at the
quarterback of the future we'll see
where that future arrived so I think
outside people looking them as bill
better than a third-place team and the
only reason they're not a fourth-place
team is people don't have much regard
for the Redskins most people don't think
they're a contender in any way shape or
form you know I think they could sneak
into the picture if a lot of things go
well and that that's the problem with
Giants is you can make a case that they
can win eight nine games you definitely
can but you have to list about five or
six things that have to go well that
aren't proven that could go well but
that has to go well and that that's a
that's a slippery slope the only way Eli
is out of the lineup obviously an injury
but can he play his way out of the
lineup this season
oh absolutely there's no question and I
think and I think that he doesn't have
to be terrible look if the team is not
great
is a decision inside the franchise that
look we're not gonna make the playoffs I
don't think we're gonna contend whether
that's after five games or eight games
or ten games whatever it is all this
Daniel Jung's talk I mean they love the
guy cuz they picked them so high that
doesn't mean they don't still look you
lie but when you have a guy waiting and
all he does is play well and make you
think good thoughts like Pat Shermer and
Dave gentlemen are thinking about him
now it will make the inevitable change
quicker so Eli Manning is really under
the gun here he asked to play well they
have to win and those are things that
are going to be hard for them to do Paul
thanks for joining us we appreciate your
time anytime thank you Dan that's Paul
Schwartz he's Giants beat writer for the
New York Post since 1994 for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]